at this point anybody who knows this
show well knows that I try not to be
hyperbolic or exaggerated when I say
this is a concern that's something we
have to worry about early in the corona
virus pandemic I got emails from some of
you that David you're being hyperbolic
about the risk of coronavirus and it
turned out that if anything I was
understating the risk that coronavirus
represented now I want to be crystal
clear with you today the authoritarian
paramilitary deployment to Portland
Oregon could well be just the beginning
a test case a trial balloon for what is
going to be a massive authoritarian
expansion over the next several weeks
leading up to the November election
earlier this week Donald Trump said he
would continue to send federal law
enforcement to more American cities
including the unmarked cars and the
unidentified forces and Trump actually
mentioned New York Chicago Philly
Detroit Baltimore Oakland as examples of
so-called as he calls it Liberal
Democrat cities where he would be
interested in sending troops now
understand that this is happening
directly counter to the requests of many
of the state and local leaders so for
example the mayor of Portland Oregon Ted
wheeler does not want the troops there
they are there anyway when acting
Secretary of Homeland Security Chad wolf
was recently interviewed about this he
was asked about the fact that many
mayors and governors don't want these
troops there he said it doesn't matter
let's take a look at the clip a towers
are just misinformed they're not
accurate they don't understand the
authorities and the responsibilities of
the Department of Homeland Security has
we protect over nine almost 9,000
federal facilities across the country we
did that 10 years ago we did it long
before this civil unrest started and
we'll continue to do that and so I don't
need invitations by the state state
mayors or state governors to do our job
we're gonna do that whether they like us
there or not that's our responsibility
so of course the hypocrisy is astounding
in that the same people who talk about
states rights and local rights are now
saying we don't care that if the federal
government wants to be there and the
governors or the mayors don't we're
going to do it anyway
so then Donald Trump's press secretary
Kaley mcenany was asked about this
yesterday and she actually cited a
specific statute and essentially
defended this action by saying the
federal government has property in these
cities and states and the federal
government is allowed to send troops to
protect that property here she is
yesterday and my second question is
where in the Constitution does the
president derive the authority to send
federal law enforcement officers to the
streets of American cities against the
will of the elected officials in those
cities yes well what you're referring to
is Portland in 40 US Code one three one
five gives DHS the ability to deputize
officers in any department or agency
like ice custom and Border Patrol and
Secret Service quote as officers and
agents they can be deputized for the
duty of in connection with the
protection of property owned or occupied
by the federal government and persons on
that property and when a federal
courthouse is being lit on fire
commercial fireworks being shot at it
being shot at the officers I think that
that falls pretty well within the limits
of 40 u.s. code 1350 that's a minor
protecting federal property like the
federal courthouse in the case of
Portland does he see limitations to that
power and how how much how far does that
power extend into the into the streets
of the city of Portland how you know
what other limitations on that to
protect a federal problem sure the law
we believe that agents can conduct
investigations of crimes committed
against federal property or federal
officers and in the case where you have
someone shooting off a commercial-grade
firework and then running across the
street we don't believe that that
extends past our jurisdiction so there's
two parts here to discuss the first is
she mentions 40 u.s. code 131 five
that's called the law enforcement
authority of Secretary of Homeland
Security for protection of property the
next part is are they merely protecting
property so what the law says is indeed
that officers and agents of DHS can be
deployed in connection with protecting
property that the federal government
owns are occupied so there might be a
property that is not federal government
property but like a federal government
office or agency is based there so those
would be the two scenarios property
owned or occupied by the federal
government
um there are two really important
limitations here though one is a
provision about authority outside
federal property where actually it says
for the protection of property owner
occupied by the phone door occupied by
the federal government the secretary may
enter into agreements with federal
agencies and state and local governments
to obtain authority for officers and
agents to enforce laws concurrently with
other federal law enforcement officers
and state and local law enforcement the
secretary may do that if state and local
authorities want but states don't want
that in the case of Portland and in
Oregon and in fact that's the next part
that's at issue here which is that Kaley
mcenany is arguing if they have to chase
someone if someone attacks a federal
building and then the troops have to
chase that person across the street
across the street she believes it is the
opinion that she says the government has
they are still within their jurisdiction
but the reality from the widespread
reports on the ground and the videos
that we're seeing are that things are
happening not just across the street
but even blocks from so-called federal
property so the framing they've set up
is hanging by a thread it only hangs
together if you blindly accept it but
the truth is the law allows federal
troops to be there concurrent with state
and local law enforcement and they may
make an agreement but the local law
enforcement does not have to make that
agreement and they are going very fast
and loose when it comes to the
definition of federal property and that
gets us to the point of all of this
during yesterday's press briefing Kaley
Mack and Annie framed this all as
violent actors are up against law
enforcement and Trump is on the correct
side Trump is going to send people in
he's going to defend us it's all going
to be great and she continued
criticizing violence of the protesters
it's really important to understand a
few things here number one the violent
incidents have increased since the
troops went in now whether they're
deliberately instigating the troops or
their mere presence is aggravating the
situation we can debate that I'm not
taking a position on that yet but the
whole point of this is number one this
is a gambit
that the more violence there is on TV
the more the country will turn against
protesters and visa vie that against or
rather in favor of Donald Trump the
second piece of it is that this is all a
test case in Portland for deploying the
troops more broadly Trump has already
given a list of cities but the
deployment may happen up to an including
through election day in order to
intimidate people this is not a trivial
matter this comes down to some of the
fundamental issues of state versus
federal rights the role of law
enforcement due process jurisdiction and
in the end it's a desperate cornered
president trying to get himself
reelected fighting for his political
life with any idea that occurs to him he
has restarted the coronavirus press
briefings we covered it yesterday live
he's sending in federal troops he's
tweeting attacks of people he's holding
press conferences where he just reads
attacks on Joe Biden off of a piece of
paper he's claiming he's aced cognitive
tests that Joe Biden and Chris Wallace
wouldn't be able to ace so at this point
this is a cornered individual desperate
for survival and on the show yesterday
as I said a dangerous Trump it a rather
a desperate Trump is a dangerous Trump
and we should all be horrified by the
potential of this if they get away with
this in Portland it's proof of concept
that they can get away with
authoritarian crackdowns in other cities
and authoritarian crackdowns that will
last a while meaning they will do more
this is a test case let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
make sure you're signed up for free to
the daily audio podcast yesterday again
three weeks in a row I've said this on
Wednesdays yesterday was the best day
ever
for the audio podcast incredible let me
tell you real quick about one of our
sponsors cuts clothing they offer super
quality men's t-shirts and they're
giving you 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash cuts that's e UTS
because solid-color t-shirts are a
really important staple in pretty much
every guy's wardrobe i think it's really
important not to overlook the value of
having t-shirts you love wear
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game-changer for me and as a company all
they deal with our men's solid-color
t-shirts so they actually put a ton of
thought into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts I've owned and they
look great this right here that I'm
wearing on youtube is the split hem crew
neck t-shirt very soft fits me perfectly
it's the ideal length go take a look at
what they offer and once you have it you
are really going to see and feel the
difference their slogan is it's the only
shirt worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS